what's up you guys it's the movie
retrospective and it's the one like
before Halloween and I didn't even like
cut I don't think I even really meant to
do this I had totally forgotten that
this movie House of a Thousand Corpses
is actually set on Halloween yeah I I
didn't realize I had forgotten I think
this is only the third time I've seen it
in the first two times I don't think I I
think I I think I saw it like an old
shitty television you know what I mean
if I can it wasn't even HD because it
looked a lot better on uh on the new
stuff I think because the last time I
saw this must have been
2010 maybe or 2008 around that 2009 yeah
I remember thinking that this movie was
okay I mean there were certain parts
that I liked it I I didn't really some
of it was real disturbing when I first
saw it I was like whoa
I didn't quite catch what the movie was
about but now that I've seen it probably
like the third time
I fully understand the
the story
because this time seeing it with with
subtitles I think helped
because there's some details that are
sometimes given that if you if it wasn't
written on the screen you probably
wouldn't have really picked it up in a
normal dialogue that's why I always like
yeah well plus I'm deaf as [ __ ] too but
that's why
I liked the movie when I first saw it
though
but now I think it's a masterpiece I
think it's I mostly saw the one that's
after this what is it the devil Devil's
Rejects I've seen that a bunch of times
I love that one
but seeing this one was like yeah this
is good too
um
I just uh the whole Dr Satan aspect I
understood it a lot better now that I've
seen it like three or three times I
didn't realize that he was trying to
make a an army of
superhumans out of a mentally ill I
didn't really catch that in the first
two viewings so now I made a lot more
sense
and the fact that that weird-ass family
was like given Dr Satan offerings so he
could add to his army
you know by sending them down into that
Dam underground dang you know where he
was where he lived that
so uh I don't know I just liked it a lot
better on third View and you know like
and some people
don't like Rob Zombie movies
I think this little series is is his
best work you know there are other ones
I like but I'm kind of more into his
like original I'm like super into him
but I'm more into his original stuff
than I am like his remakes yeah he
should have just done more stuff like
this I don't think the Remake thing no
it's kind of like he's trying to
do what uh oh what's his name did with
all the remakes what's the [ __ ] Tim
Burton Tim Burton you know Tim Burton's
original stuff is pretty good but when
he does remix I don't really like him
yeah
um same thing you know well that's the
thing and I kind of feel like and that's
kind of a good analogy like with Tim
Burton because it's like they have such
a cool vision of their own yeah that
it's like I kind of just wish they would
do their own [ __ ] instead of like
adapting other people's stuff all the
time yeah like he just redid the
monsters and I've seen clips of it I'm
just not interested in seeing that I'm
just like nah yeah it doesn't really
look good to me
I just and even if it's good I don't
wanna I don't really care about seeing
it if it was more stuff like this more
original [ __ ] that he dreamed up
like yeah I'd like to see it there's
only one story I think that he could
probably
do a remake that I'd probably like it
and that would be the Omega Man
he understand he likes that story and he
likes [ __ ] last man on Earth I'd like
to see his version of
Omega Man
yeah I actually wouldn't mind seeing it
I think he could be about that real well
because I
he's written you know written songs
about it he understands those two movies
and I think he could make a really good
Omega Man
one where the mutants talk
and you could do it like a mixture of
the [ __ ] uh uh uh [ __ ] Charlton
Heston movie and the Vincent Price movie
you could make that into one coherent
movie that homage both you could do it
he could do it
as long as you didn't get too silly
yeah but I mean the thing about it and I
saw like House of a Thousand Corpses I
actually saw this in the theater when it
came out
um I wasn't like super into Rob Zombie's
music or anything like I thought it was
okay and stuff but I saw the trailer for
it and I was like that looks pretty cool
uh and I really liked kind of the
throwback you know uh Grindhouse kind of
vibe to it because you have to think
that this came out in 2003 and I feel
like a lot of horror from like the late
90s and early 2000s like a lot of it was
kind of like remakes and a lot of it was
kind of like big studios trying to get
into horror so they were kind of like
PG-13 uh you know kind of just lame ass
slashers and stuff so this looks real
grotty and gross and it's like that
looks like something different so it
looked like something I wanted to see I
remember liking it but not loving it so
I really did want to like revisit it and
on a re-watch I think I might like this
one better than the Devil's Rejects
because even though the Devil's Rejects
I think is like a more coherent movie
um this one I feel like is a lot more
fun it's artistic and a lot more stylish
yeah stylish even though it's very over
caffeinated like you can tell that this
was Rob Zombies like he was super
excited to like make a movie it works
though but yeah and it's like it I mean
it plays out like a you know like a 90
minute music video essentially but
that's okay I think that's kind of like
one of the strong points of it is that
he obviously just took like everything
that he loved and everything that he
thought was gonna look cool and put it
into one movie and it's like like I said
it might be too much for some people but
you can really see his like enthusiasm
it's supposed to be kind of cartoonish
anyway right kind of cartoonish with
over-the-top Grindhouse [ __ ] edits
and weird [ __ ] that it it's supposed to
take place in the 70s and then some of
the film looks like it was shot in the
70s and it's just gritty grimy but then
there are elements of [ __ ] over the
top fun in it
and it's a Halloween movie it works it
works I think it's a great movie I think
it's a masterpiece I think it's a
masterpiece I mean I really really like
I particularly like all the set design
now I don't know if you know this but
this movie actually started life as
Universal Studios I mean uh Rob Zombie
obviously was in White Zombie and then
he was he directed like all of his own
music videos and stuff like that too
yeah yeah but so um so Universal Studios
actually asked him to do uh a maze a
house at uh Universal Studios like uh
Halloween Horror Nights like not the one
in Orlando but the one in Hollywood
so their concept was House of a Thousand
Corpses and they asked Rob Zombie to do
it so while he was working on that they
were kind of like
um hey that actually might be a good
movie do you have any ideas in that
regard and Rob Zombie was like well I
went in there to the meeting and I
didn't really have anything ready so I
just kind of pulled some stuff out my
ass and they were like that's cool make
that so they gave him I think the
initial budget was like four million
dollars
and so he started making it
and then
um like he's like well we didn't really
have enough money to like do a good
ending so he's like so we did like a
sucky ending because I figured if I did
a sucky ending then they would give me
more money to improve it and that worked
uh they did that so they gave him I'm
not sure what the final budget was I've
seen seven million I've seen 14 million
whatever it was so he made it and then
he showed it to Universal and he's like
I told them ahead of time before I
showed them the thing he's like I don't
want to make a mainstream horror movie I
want to make like a Grindhouse Drive-In
kind of movie I want it to be weird I
wanted to be disgusting and grotesque
and they seemed fine with that
um so like I said they gave him the
money he showed it to them and they were
like we think this is gonna get an NC-17
and we can't have that so they decided
to stick it on a shelf this movie was
actually made in 2000 uh you know and it
sat on a shelf for like several years so
Universal is like okay well we don't
want to release it because
it's not gonna you know if you have an
nc17 like a lot of theaters won't play
it so then he went to mg like MGM
approached him and said well we'll
release it uh but then Rob Zombie made a
joke about MGM like I think he said
something like
um oh well the you know MGM they don't
have any morals so they'll release it
hahaha you know what I mean like a joke
and MGM did not like that and said well
[ __ ] you we're not releasing it now
dumbasses so yeah so Rob Zombie actually
bought the rights back so he's like well
[ __ ] [ __ ] you I'll just release it
myself but then Lions Gate the the
studio came forward and said well we'll
release it so they put it out
um the thing about it though is that I
don't know if they're ever going to show
like the uncut version anywhere is that
what we saw no we saw um the theatrical
cut as far as I know the only time
that they completely uncut version has
ever shown was one time at a film
festival in Argentina
and after that like it got cut out so
there is a version the version we saw
which is the very very common version is
89 minutes there was a longer version
that was 104 minutes and I think that
the initial like director's cut or
whatever you want to call it was
actually I guess it would be 89 minutes
but it was 40 minutes longer than that
damn so um not been very good though
well see I heard I don't know I've never
seen it um and a lot of people haven't
seen it
so I heard that most of the stuff that
got taken out was stuff having to do
with Sherry moon like they said there
was like some scenes of her like
masturbating with a skeleton there was
stuff like that I don't think a lot of
the gore was cut out right I think it
was more sexual stuff yeah so which like
I said that that tracks they'll leave
all the violence in but you know you
can't have a woman like looking like
she's enjoying sex in a movie
well that too but it's like well you
know what's weird is I saw those little
clips of that though they did though but
I think yeah I think it was like much
longer probably just not very good
probably yeah because [ __ ] a movie
has to keep rolling along it can't get
bogged down in little things when it
does it starts to become boring you know
just watch [ __ ] blade three you know
[ __ ] that [ __ ] gets bogged down like
[ __ ] crazy yeah so probably just
trimming it up editing it for time
probably helped the movie I imagine it
probably did because the thing about
this one because what I was gonna what I
was getting at with the whole this
actually started out as like not
necessarily like a ride but like a an
attraction at Universal Studios and the
movie actually really does play like
that it plays like you're going to
Universal Studios and you're going
through like a like a house like at
Halloween Horror Nights I think actually
Universal Studios even before this movie
came out like I said because it started
out as its life as that they did the
trailer for it and they did the um the
Halloween Horror Nights house they
called it American Nightmare though
that's originally it was supposed to be
called House of a Thousand Corpses and
then they changed the name so uh I think
they did it in 2003 or 2004 and then
like they showed the trailer beforehand
but then it was like
um they did Like Houses based on this
movie like subsequently I think the most
recent one I think in 2019 they did a
house that was like based on this as
well but it's weird because I had like
like I said I remembered liking this
movie but it's a lot better than I
remembered it's also kind of like
it's kind of all over the place and Rob
Zombie has said that as well but I kind
of feel like if you approach it more as
an experience like I said like a ride
then it's a lot better because I kind of
feel like his you know and this is not
really [ __ ] on him too much but his
script writing is not his the strongest
suit I kind of feel like the coolest
thing about this movie is just like the
way it looks like the aesthetic the
whole retro thing and Sid Hague uh being
like I mean Sid Hague [ __ ] steals oh
so [ __ ] sexy ass Karen Black checks
yeah I always preface Karen Black's name
with sexy ass
[Laughter]
my dad was my dad's favorite woman
yeah he didn't tell my mom that was his
favorite movie's drama dad and and I
didn't really see it you know when I got
a little bit older I said yeah she is
[ __ ] sexy yeah but he liked the fact
that she kind of had a slightly lazy eye
I think she got that fixed
because remember that when she was young
I think she slightly had a little bit of
a laser well I don't know because you
can kind of see it in this movie too my
dad thought that [ __ ] was so sexy and um
she looks great in this movie how old is
she in this movie I don't know this
movie like I said this movie was made in
2000 so it's so over 20 years old 23
years old yeah uh but I would think she
was probably 60s
uh she's gotta be sure how she would
have to be I'd imagine she looks great
though you know she does look right in
there she'd be right next to her [ __ ]
moons what's her name Moon zapper
[ __ ] Cherry Moon
yeah [ __ ] Moon okay it's like in
California all right um
yeah they they
both look like stuck in hot chicks from
different Generations but bad you know
what I mean like [ __ ]
Karen Black's got [ __ ] bad teeth in
it you know what I mean yeah but there's
just something about her it's you know
[ __ ] she's evil you know and she's
trying to be really coming on to people
and being sexy and [ __ ] but [ __ ] you
know you know that that's like a damn
Black Widow if you get involved in that
[ __ ] if I could kill you it's just it's
just a good character real good
character yeah she has a really good
character and honestly it's kind of like
um you can see why some of these
characters like became so iconic and you
know how they got like a whole franchise
later on but yeah and you can tell too
that Rob Zombie was like way more into
the villains than he was into but he
even said that because
I kind of feel like um you know the
villains were really interesting and
like the kids they're not really kids
but they're like young adults that come
there and get [ __ ] up he basically
knew he's like well in horror movies
nobody really gives a [ __ ] about the
kids everybody's just like all about the
villains which is not entirely true but
in a lot of uh kind of exploitation
sentiment is so you can see like where
he was coming from with that the earlier
you said his scripts weren't that
weren't his strong suit I think it
depends that's true in his
and his original stuff I think the
scripts are good I think the script is
good in this I don't know how it was
originally written
but it was trimmed down and massaged
into a good movie that's really all the
script has to be you know I mean you
have to result in a good movie and I
think it did so I wouldn't be that hard
on him about the script writing and just
I think I just didn't like the the
script the scripts from some of the you
know remake stuff that he did I don't
think they're that good but yeah or not
that interesting you know I'd much
rather
see him do original [ __ ]
yeah I would as well and and like I said
re-watching this because the Devil's
Rejects I like The Devil's Rejects but
that is a much more like mean-spirited
movie yeah that one's kind of disturbing
this one is too but this one at least
has like that kind of like overblown
like Carnival aspect to it which I found
really appealing very much like Texas
Chainsaw Massacre was it two or three
the [ __ ] crazy one where they go down
and under two it was two yeah the one
with Dennis tone is kind of like yeah it
is yeah tone is kind of like that and I
think it's on purpose well yeah he's
like it's almost like it's happening in
the same universe I liked him he's in
some of the scenes in this movie are
direct homages like the whole dinner
scene and everything like that or direct
demages to uh and you know bring Grandpa
and all that kind of stuff
Texas chains although Texas Chainsaw
Massacre was not funny like that it was
like really really disturbing whereas
this one is kind of more I don't know if
I'd go as far as to call this a black
comedy Wikipedia does but it there's a
lot of humor in it and actually Rob
Zombie said I didn't mean for this movie
to be funny necessarily or campy but it
just kind of came out like that as we
were making it so we just said [ __ ] it
that's just the direction the movie
wants to go in yeah so that's the
direction that it went in that's a good
call yeah and I think that that was my
re-watching it I think that was my
favorite thing about it was like the
humor and just like this over the top
like all that crazy like Sideshow kind
of because I really do like that
aesthetic yeah so I realistically yeah
so I kind of got and I was watching a
couple other Reviews of This and like
some a lot of horror channels are like
you know they don't love it or whatever
but they're just kind of like it's good
to like put on it's like you don't even
need the um you know you can just put it
on mute like in the background of a
Halloween party I think like uh Corey
Leach said that and he's liking it
because it looks so cool
um you know it's like the story doesn't
make a huge amount of sense but that's
okay like I said it's kind of like a
ride I had totally forgotten one that
[ __ ] rain Wilson Dwight from the
office was in this and I forgot that
Chris [ __ ] Hardwick was in this from
Talking Dead yeah I was like as soon as
I saw him like holy [ __ ] like Chris
Harwick and he gets very effective and
the dude that played the damn serial
rapist was in it from uh Predators
remember they went on that yeah yeah
yeah dude that was in the orange
jumpsuit yeah as the deputy that's a
good job in this movie he's in a lot of
movies actually like he's a great
character after he can play a real good
scumbag yeah or or I mean that's a niche
that some people have that's one we were
just talking about the other day with
Miguel Ferrer like and yeah
he played like an awesome hey you know
you played your strength that's what you
do and the thing about a likable dick
he's a dick but you kind of you which is
a hard thing to pull off I mean you know
what I mean like some people are just
better at playing villains and you just
have to lean into that [ __ ] you know
what I mean and it's funny because I
kind of feel like a lot of people
they're really famous for playing
terrible people or villains are like the
nicest people ever in real life which I
think is really fun Michael Rooker nice
guy yeah everybody says he's like the
nicest dude ever but then he plays like
[ __ ] the biggest scum
Michael Rooker from another Mississippi
boy he's just you know hey go back go
back in time and look at Michael Rucker
when he's young and in in his prime and
he was a good looking guy but he never
got any kind of romantic leads he was
always
you know Henry Henry Lee Lucas you know
[ __ ] serial killer type you know but
and I always feel like that's such a
shame because I personally I kind of
find character actors if you want to
call it that a lot more interesting
because they're distinctive yeah
um I kind of feel like people that are
kind of like big a-listers and stuff
like that sometimes they're fine actors
but they're kind of like samey yeah
because like I said they all go to the
same plastic surgeon they all look like
super perfect and everything like that
and that's like not that interesting to
me it's just not interesting Rooker kind
of had that damn Daniel Craig kind of
tough guy he's rough around there yeah
yeah he had that right right
now we you were asking last night about
um when we were watching uh House of a
Thousand Corpses you were asking about
the guy that played tiny yeah big huge
guy I bought into it was it real yes uh
that guy he's sadly passed away at the
age of 32. yeah okay congestive heart
failure yeah but um yeah Matthew mcgrory
was that guy's name giantism uh yeah
well it's uh he was probably because he
was seven foot six seven foot six I knew
the proportions were wrong and I was
like deck I don't think that stilts in
those legs the where they no that's
actually him yeah and actually when I
looked at his Wikipedia page
yeah when I looked at his Wikipedia page
he always he played a lot of roles like
that obviously like he played like a lot
of monsters and yeah [ __ ] like that he
was even in some video I think he was in
like a Marilyn Manson video and some
[ __ ] like that but yeah so like I said
he's sad he died like really really
young but sometimes like people with
that uh Affliction don't usually live
yeah
he was he was actually in the um
Guinness Book of World Records as like
world's tallest actor okay and uh
according to his Wikipedia page he was
also in there for world's longest toes
okay so there's and he had like huge
feet they said he were like 29 and a
half size 29 and a half something like
that so yeah that was I mean obviously
they put burned [ __ ] on him yeah but um
but yeah he was seven foot six so uh
yeah because I was interested to like
look him up you know what I'm saying I
knew something wasn't right it didn't
look like a costume it wasn't yeah
that's really what he looks like that's
really what he looked like but um yeah
now I okay so like I said Sid Hague is
great in this I kind of I had forgotten
I thought Sid Hague was in it more I
guess I was thinking of the later movies
where he's more of his character this
one he's almost kind of like he's at the
beginning which is great like in the
opening part and then he doesn't really
show up again until the end and then you
don't because in Devil's Rejects don't
they establish that that Captain
Spaulding is baby's dad
I think so I don't know because in this
one in this one they don't like say that
he's related to them he's just like
working with them obviously but they
don't say that well they can't say that
to the very end and then you realize
that he's not saving the girl that he's
[ __ ] taking her back to [ __ ] a doctor
with Dr Satan yeah so he was he that he
knew him all along and uh yeah that
first one third of the movie it feels
like a sid egg movie Sid this [ __ ]
acting his ass off he's [ __ ]
hilarious and it's [ __ ] scary
[ __ ] spooky in it I mean he's like
this motherfucker's nuts and I was
watching and I was going man that
reminds me of my uncle Wilson
Michael Wilson was like Sid Hague I
guess doing campus balding but he wasn't
[ __ ] a killer he was just a [ __ ]
that you know and he was skinny yeah he
was real skinny but he had that same
Expressions until jokes one day he
decided he wanted to die just drank
himself to death it took him about a
month
just and his family tried to stop he's
like oh [ __ ] they laid him off at work
and he didn't want he didn't want to
live anymore
that's [ __ ] up yeah for telling
[ __ ] bad jokes at work
you know what I mean looking it was in
the 1970s you can't tell if I couldn't
have done it sex jokes and [ __ ] those
kind of jokes and [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
posting them so everybody can see him he
got fired for that she got laid off got
laid off when he retired they made him
retire he went home and dragged himself
to death
yeah my aunt Krista who's my dad's
sister who
couldn't stop him he went to the
hospital twice he says I'm going right
back to drinking when he gets because
his [ __ ] livers were shutting down at
everybody he says I'm out of here and
they're like all right they just gotta
let him drink himself to death he stayed
outside in a damn trailer but he had a
camper he had to Camp around the back
living that damn camper wouldn't even
come into the [ __ ] house
damn this thing yeah yeah and my cousin
couldn't stop him yeah
yeah sad but so not so not as fun as Sid
Hague then uh no he was [ __ ]
hilarious I mean like the way that it
ended yeah no my uncle Wilson although
City passed away it was just old
Louisiana Cajun and it was like that you
know yeah but he wasn't a villain he was
just a crazy funny [ __ ] dude but I
mean he was your uncle that you're
[ __ ] 14 and he give he starts letting
you drink right he's one of those we all
had one of those shoes then he'd drive
around with you in the car because you
could have open container in Louisiana
back in those in those days and I'm
driving around like I'm an adult
drinking with my uncle at like [ __ ]
14.
yeah yeah funny but yeah I mean like I
said Sid Higgs stole this movie and uh
well I've forgotten like how little of
the movie he was in because like I said
I was thinking of the later ones that
I've seen more often uh Bill Mosley is
great in this too he's always great and
everything well he was Bill Mosley was
in Texas Chainsaw Massacre too he played
Chop top so that's why he was uh you
know in this one all of the weird like
rants that he does
um you know because where they have like
all his interstitials that were shot in
like Rob Zombie's basement that they
just kind of like that he could kind of
put in between all the scenes
um he said that he based a lot of those
like the stuff that Sherry moon was
doing and the stuff that bill Mosley was
doing where they were just like [ __ ]
around like in the basement he wanted
those to be like
um he's like if the Manson family had
made Home Videos he's like he wanted
that to be that kind of vibe to it so uh
so that's what some of this because Bill
Mosley is just in there like saying all
kind of crazy [ __ ] it's like it doesn't
really make any sense but he was trying
to you know kind of get that Manson
family Vibe
um I will say I think like Sherry Moon
got better later on uh she's not a great
actress at this it's hard to tell though
I mean and that laugh is just like so so
annoying that laugh that she does I mean
it's part of her character but it could
be the character it's hard to tell
I think overall she's effective she got
the job done she did do the character
that may have been what their character
was intended to be well I guess it was
yeah or at least that's the way she came
off and they're like that's good enough
yeah she doesn't ruin the movie by any
means I think she does kind of add her
own quality to the movie you know she is
cute
um she's all in yeah you know what I
mean she's not phoning it in she's no
not at all so
I've heard that complain about her and I
I kind of saw what they were talking
about but on further viewing I'm like
I'm further viewing I said no I think
it's acceptable I think she's pretty
good I think that's the way the
character is supposed to be because
she's memorable yeah she's memorable
although he does and she is unique yeah
um and when you look at [ __ ] real
serial killer footage
it's like they're role-playing that's
like when you look Charles Yang and all
that kind of stuff they don't look
realistic when they're filming
themselves with the victim it looks like
it's a [ __ ] fake B movie well that's
the way she comes off
is like
real fake and artificial and LARPing but
that's the way serial killers are on
tape when you see them
I did like the one scene where she was
uh where they do like the show like on
the stage uh where she's lip syncing
yeah she did a great job to that so like
I like that outfit and I just I liked
that uh that scene I thought that was
like really good yeah so she she
people too hard on her well that's his
girlfriend he's gonna put his girlfriend
up there but she does have talent she
did bring some stuff to to the two
movies you know yeah I think well no I
say like I I think she got better like
in later movies I guess this was like
her first one yeah so you can tell that
she was kind of like because the second
one I remember her being great in the
second one
yeah I haven't seen the second one in a
while we gotta see that second one again
but I remember I remember uh I remember
it being great yeah she was better in
that one yeah like in this one she just
seemed a little bit
like I kind of feel like she should have
like dialed it back just like it's like
a notch or two just a notch or two
that's Direction
well yeah that's the director okay I
know that's what he wanted or he thought
it was acceptable so yeah it works it
works yeah I mean like yeah I mean the
whole vibe of the movie is just kind of
like like I said grotesqueries it's just
kind of like a circus act yeah and if
you approach it with that in mind and or
like I said like a ride where you know
[ __ ] doesn't necessarily have to make
sense necessarily but it's just kind of
like oh the next thing is just like oh
here's another cool thing you know what
I mean and as long as you come at it
like that then I think it works really
well and like I said visually it's
really really cool I do get that like
some people like I know it's not
everybody's cup of tea like that super
uh [ __ ]
um like editing and stuff and like where
he just sticks all these like filters
and all that kind of stuff and I think
if another I don't know I kind of feel
like if another filmmaker had done that
it would probably just like piss me off
but because it's Rob Zombie and that's
like his thing
um I don't think it bothers me as much
and I fit and I kind of feel like too I
just like that he's homaging I saw like
a couple of reviews that said he's con
he's almost like the Quentin Tarantino
of I was gonna say that of horror movies
like I've seen a couple reviews that
said that remind his dialogue in his in
the movies and it's kind of the subject
matter and the presentation kind of
reminds me of Tarantino at times I mean
it's Quentin Tarantino that's a
scratching he you know I mean that's not
bad I'm not slagging on him because
Tarantino's grips are actually like a
lot better like a lot cleverer like his
dialogue and stuff I feel like Tarantino
does some good stuff uh his body I don't
like everything but he does do some good
stuff yeah it's similar because you can
tell that they're like homaging they
love all these old movies they love all
this old [ __ ] and they're trying to like
trying to convey their enthusiasm for it
and I feel like that's yeah they're
trying to make it a Vibe like a like
like a they're trying to bring life back
into that right style of cinema right so
which yeah I get that and like I said
it's not going to be for everybody and
that's okay but but watching this movie
again I actually visually I actually
like this one more than the later ones
now because the later ones I feel like
went more in the vein of not only just
like mean-spirited but more grounded in
reality it looked more like Texas
Chainsaw Massacre for example which is
like these warm deserty realistic tones
this one is a lot more cartoonish and I
think that works in its favor
um you know but I couldn't remember
because it had been so long since I'd
seen this one I want to see the other
two though
yeah two more in there yeah there's
Devil's Rejects and uh three from hell
that's right three I wanna I wanna see
the other which we saw three from hell
not too long ago but I don't remember a
lot about it I remember yeah it was okay
it was okay it didn't like stick out to
me yeah like I said I had to see it
again yeah a lot of a lot of times it's
your mental state when you see the movie
that's true that's why if I if I like
something or I thought it was like okay
I'll usually like give it another go
like after a while just to make sure
that it wasn't in a bad mood like the
first time that I watched it but I kind
of feel like when this movie came out
like it got a lot of negative reviews
but apparently it struck a chord a
little bit because it did kind of like
start building up a cult following it
didn't it made money I mean it obviously
made enough money for you know them to
be like hey you know do a house based on
it at Universal Studios and hey like
make two more movies but I kind of feel
like it didn't really find its footing
until it came out like on DVD and then
like it started getting Word of Mouth
another thing that I I remembered this
movie being a lot grosser or like a lot
more graphic like as far as Gore
um and there is some but not as much as
I remembered you know what I'm saying
and it's not so much that I saw the
uncut version and like now I've seen the
cut version because apparently the uncut
version hasn't been shown anywhere so
there's no way I could have seen it so
maybe I'm just I was remembering it more
because like I said you had to think of
it too in the context of the time where
a lot of horror movies that came out
like in the early 2000s were a lot kind
of like wimpier you know what I mean
like not as graphic and this one was
like a lot like dirty or grimier and
more graphic but by today's standards
it's not really all that gory like I
said I think the goriest thing is when
they show uh the guy from The Talking
Dead being like vivisected but it's not
really but the way that's edited like
you can't really see a lot of it
anything explicit that's what I'm saying
it's not real explicit it's just a lot
of it's just imagery yeah tone and
dialogue and the the sound effects
and you see the results of what happened
like he they made a fish boy and that
was creepy I like that yeah she didn't
show it happened they made Dwight from
the office yeah fish boy yeah it didn't
show it happened but it weirds you out
uh they don't show a lot of it happening
yeah you just see like the aftermath
yeah
yeah whereas like I said I feel like The
Devil's Rejects was more kind of
throwing you in the in the middle of the
thing with them and the victims and like
them actually torturing the victims in
real time yeah whereas in this one you
just kind of saw like glimpses of it and
then you just saw what happened like
afterward but like in a way like I said
that made it more fun even though it was
people getting [ __ ] up
still and really nobody escaped or
anything like that but made it totally
real similar to Texas Chainsaw Massacre
II yeah what I remember of Texas
chainsaw yeah like a little bit more
goofy yeah I don't want to call it goofy
but a little more
it was more entertainment based it's um
yeah
more kind of like a little video game
like old video game like Splatterhouse
or something yeah you know like not so
much trying to like disturb you yeah
right yeah but just trying to like make
you have a good time yeah trying to
entertain you and [ __ ] trip you out
over you know [ __ ] yeah it's not really
trying to you know Human Centipede you
or anything it's not trying to give you
yeah not trying to like put you ass to
mouth right yeah yeah sure
um
yeah yeah it's just it's a good time
yeah uh but yeah so um I guess that'll
do it for our little Halloween movie
retrospective here and uh so let us know
in the comments what you think about
house a thousand corpses what you think
about Rob Zombie's original movies in
general because I actually liked this
one better I'd so I can't remember I saw
it in the theater I know that but I
might have seen it one time after that
but it's been like a really long time
it's been ages since I've seen it so it
was really nice to see it again and I
actually did like it better the second
time like I said visually it's really
really cool but yeah that'll do it for
this movie retrospective we'll see you
guys again on the next one bye